[Music]
hey how you doing good how you doing all
right I'm 2 Chainz welcome to TWA Tyler
Morse nice to meet you Tyler nice to
meet you as well
you want me to call you Mr chains I love
Mr Sands yeah we're going with the
chance today's episode Mr chains and Mr
Tyler James does TWA
now tell me what TWA stands for
Transworld Airlines okay and am I in an
airport right now you're not you're in a
hotel but this is a former TWA terminal
this was the original Cathedral to
Aviation it was built by Howard Hughes
when he owned TWA was designed by Arrow
serenin who did the St Louis Arch tulip
table the Tulip chair all the stuff that
we sit on these days okay and Howard
Hughes he was the richest guy in the
world he called aerosarin and said I
want the greatest airplane terminal the
world's ever seen
and I don't care how much it cost this
was the product of that this is
spectacular airplane terminal it was
functionally obsolete the day it opened
in 1962. too small really well they used
it but as you can see everybody came
into the building that way the baggage
claim was invented right there
[Music]
foreign
too small now we have functional
Solari board split flat board and this
is from the 60s no I had this remade
okay to mirror the exact one that was
here in 1962. you got to go to Venice
okay and drive two hours North and they
will sell this to you for two million
bucks
that's all two million bucks two million
it's essentially a clock
I love it I look at all the Vintage
logos right yeah those are all the ones
from 1962. that was the year we opened
we actually trademarked the year 1962
for this project how can you do that oh
I called the U.S patent and trademark
office and I trademarked it I own the
year 1962.
[Music]
speed John Glenn
the Cuban crisis of 1962. not because
they are easy but because they are hard
Monroe is dead at 36. how
how did y'all let this man on this job
did you come in and do a lot of
renovating yourself or did you try to
leave some of the details we renovated
this building to exactly as it was in
1962. okay there's 6548
000 of these Penny tiles and you notice
they're on the vertical surfaces as well
yeah see they surround the Solari board
here they were laid one thumb at a time
one thumb at a time one thumb at a time
how much would that process run you know
your average Joe it's probably five
bucks a thumb five bucks a thumb times
six million
do the math just for the floor just for
the floor Wow Let's look around yeah
with the Solari board and this is the
airport on the other side correct that's
the JetBlue terminal this has to be the
coolest thing in the world so we built
two buildings next to it these two
towers that I'm Marshall that are 512
Keys we had to dig out there under the
runway that goes down four stories
that's actually the roof of a four-story
building that's are really amazing am I
the only one just finding out about this
I I feel like I am I feel like I'm late
to the party how many people like
annually what do you see coming in now
these days uh we see a hundred thousand
people a week
so about five million people a year this
airport hotel is the sexiest thing I've
ever seen
thank you all right we're going upstairs
now not the pay phones oh my goodness
authentic pay phones you can put a dime
in there too you have a dime who has a
dime what else we got we built our own
power plant for this project we're
completely off of the electrical grid we
have a battery pack up there it's kind
of like this project is powered by a
Tesla well and it never goes off
what would something like that cost to
get done that was close to 20 million
bucks I replaced every window in this
building as well so I had to put in
tempered glass this building from a
distance you can see a green aura that's
because of the lead content so I had to
match that lead content exactly and
every single pane is different from
every other pain in size and that sounds
like a pain
[Music]
[Laughter]
Catch Me If You Can this is crazy this
is the famous scene where uh Tom Hanks
catches Leo I gotta show you the pool as
the Sun is setting what but look at that
Sunset see that's Runway four left and
22 right over there so this is a Vibe so
if you're down in the pool you're just
watching the planes take off and laugh I
love it see there's a big piece of heavy
metal coming in from Europe okay oh he's
probably going to Atlanta
wait
wait you missed your ride wait come back
get away from her stuff right now
stepping on her Road she doesn't even
know you
know
I agree and and
we don't know you either
lady all right be good grouchy ass old
people old white people that's what
would be
grounds get out of Hippo Karen call the
police you mean for no reason just angry
lady my mood up well I just don't
be with that energy man and then
the Rope she's talking about is the one
that you gave her at the hotel it's not
her personal Versace robe it's the white
one that he clearly didn't try to step
on
they filmed Ocean's eight here as well
was Rihanna in that one yeah yeah
she was hey darling how are you
oh thank you so nice I love that way to
be nice
it's a mean of all the white people up
there y'all are nice thank you she
called me handsome too you beautiful
baby
[Music]
that's right that's right that's right
great drama on the roof somebody love
this cologne see the world loves me and
when you don't
[Music]
and that plane used to be Air Force One
wow so you'll appreciate this so that
actual plane it was an Alaskan bush
plane for about 10 years then it was
bought by a bunch of South American drug
dealers uh and they ferried weed and
cocaine on that plane from Colombia to
Miami really for another 10 years it
flies low and slow so they put a cargo
door on the back side of it and they'd
air drop weed
so Rand rugs those are your peeps
has more history than anything on this
property that's legendary and you just
have it sitting in the backyard of your
oh it's a cocktail body
functional oh yeah let's go get a drink
welcome
smells like y'all drinking on you
what's up
you're good I think we got to do it
gonna go in the wing all right let's do
it I gotta go through the window
yeah how'd you think we were gonna get
out of the way this is the emergency
exit
they don't pay me that much
you know to be doing all this old
y'all especially with the old lab mean
lady all right we out here on a huge
Wing hopefully no one slips off
it's more fun out here
oh we got some bounce on
hell no
I ain't with that look like a
little scale kind of
you know the thing is I feel like if
anything happened to me I would be okay
and I know you have the money to make
sure that my family will be just so
happy with you tricking me to come out
on this damn Wing I'll drive you to the
hospital you're not
as you can see this place is huge it's
very creative done by one of the best
developers out here on the face of this
Earth I appreciate you for showing me
around definitely didn't know what I was
getting myself into but this is very
cool and I want all y'all to check it
out when you come to JFK most expensive
I'm your host two shines
[Music]
foreign